[MUSIC PLAYING]
ELISSE ROCHE: My
name is Elisse Roche,
and I lead our data for social
and environmental impact
initiatives here
at Google Cloud.
And I'm very excited to
talk to you all today
about the circular
economy, sustainability,
and the opportunities to advance
sustainability with technology.
And also, to kick off an
exciting panel discussion
as well.
Now, before we actually jump
into the circular economy
more specifically
and in particular,
want to take a step back and
actually talk a little bit more
about what
sustainability really is,
why are we talking about
why is it important today.
So kind of setting the stakes,
in 2018, the global demand
for resources was 1.7
times what the Earth
can support in one year.
Between our agricultural,
energy, and consumption
practices, we are currently
consuming more resources
than the Earth can support.
A circular economy aims to
redefine growth and focus
on positive society-wide
benefits in three key ways,
by designing out
waste and pollution,
by keeping products
and materials in use,
and even regenerating
natural systems.
Now, what's really at the
core of the circular economy
is this idea of
decoupling economic growth
from resource use.
And it also has the opportunity
to generate $4.5 trillion
of new economic output,
especially when considering
the advances in technology
that we have today,
considering machine learning
and AI in particular.
But what is a circular economy?
What are tangible examples
of a circular economy?
Well, according to the
Ellen MacArthur Foundation,
who developed the diagram
that you see pictured here,
a circular economy seeks
to rebuild capital,
whether that is financial,
manufactured, social,
or natural.
This allows, then,
for a continuous flow
of technical and
biological materials
or nutrients into
these value circles.
So as you can see,
they're quite broad.
There are agricultural inputs.
There are electronic inputs.
And as a result,
the circular economy
can take a variety
of shapes and forms.
It can be a bio-based material
for single-use food containers.
So what is pictured
here is actually
an example of a disposable cup
made from the cassava root.
And so while this is more
environmentally friendly
and compostable, it actually
is additive to the environment
as well, and helps to
promote soil regeneration.
A circular economy can also be
a rooftop hydroponic-based farm,
where 1 acre of
previously-unused roof space
can feed up to 2,000 people
per year with fresh produce.
And a circular economy is
also an e-recycling model
for electric vehicles.
As we know, there's
an increasing demand
for electric vehicles,
and that is also
matched by an increasing
demand for the batteries that
power them.
And there's then
the question of,
how can we recycle the
precious minerals, materials,
et cetera, that went into
making those batteries?
But what are Google
Cloud and SAP
doing around sustainability?
How are we driving innovation?
Well, looking at the
partnership more broadly,
Google Cloud and SAP announced
our partnership in 2017
with the goal of
giving customers
the best of both worlds,
essentially unmatched business
expertise, industry-leading
cloud infrastructure,
and machine learning solutions.
So together, we provide the
flexibility and the performance
necessary in order to
drive impactful decisions
for customers around the world.
We work together,
and we work for you.
Now, in addition to this, we can
also help organizations scale
sustainably.
From Google sustainable
data centers,
where 100% of
global energy use is
matched with renewable energy,
to the 91% landfill diversion
rate that we have
achieved in 2017.
And looking at SAP and
their sustainable solutions,
what they're working towards.
Making wind energy more
cost-effective, for example,
with customers, and also helping
to simplify risk management.
Overall, together, we
believe that investing
in environmentally
responsible management
means investing in a
collaborative future.
And that is where Circular
Economy 2030 comes in,
where Google Cloud and SAP--
and now you-- can come
together to create
a more sustainable world.
Circular Economy
2030 is a contest.
It is a sustainability contest
for social entrepreneurs, where
we asked applicants
around the world
to submit a proposal for
a revenue-generating idea
that advances a circular
economy and also
SDG 12, one of the United
Nations Sustainable Development
Goals that range from taking
climate action to promoting
gender equality.
SDG 12 is focused on responsible
consumption and production
in particular, and
so it's very closely
tied to the concept of
the circular economy.
From the applicants, the top
five eligible submissions
are to receive funding,
Google Cloud Credits, and also
mentorship opportunities.
And there's also an additional
phase of the competition that
is taking place this week,
an in-person hackathon here
in San Francisco this weekend,
where the finalists will
be competing for the
opportunity to win
the grand prize of $200,000
and in-kind benefits
across funding, and
Cloud Credits in addition
to the mentorship opportunities
and the Google Cloud
for Startups boot
camp experience.
And we're not doing this alone.
It's not just Google
Cloud and SAP.
We're also working with
leading IGOs and nonprofits
in this space, including
UN Environment, the Global
Partnership for Sustainable
Development Data,
and the Ellen
MacArthur Foundation.
So with that, we're about
to announce the finalists.
I'd like to welcome my colleague
Jim from SAP to the stage.
JAMES SULLIVAN: Awesome.
Thank you so much, Elisse.
ELISSE ROCHE: Wonderful.
So the finalists.
A quick note before we dive in.
We received over
250 applications
from over 50 countries
around the world,
which is really exciting.
So the fun fact is from every
continent except Antarctica.
JAMES SULLIVAN: Exactly.
ELISSE ROCHE: Which is great.
And definitely
spent a lot of time
reviewing these applications.
Worked really hard
on this also with
an interdisciplinary
and cross-industry panel
of expert judges, and are happy
to introduce them all to you
today.
So the first finalist, the
first social entrepreneur
is Ann Runnel from
Reverse Resources
focused on textile waste.
Reverse Resources' vision
is to help textile material
flows reach their highest
environmental potential value
so that the need
for new materials
can be minimized globally.
JAMES SULLIVAN: Thanks.
The second finalist
is Dysmus Kisilu,
and his company is Solar Freeze.
They are pioneering
portable cold storage units
powered by solar energy for
small-scale rural farmers
of perishable product.
So it's a company that's
looking at the food waste topic
from a developing
country perspective,
and also converts the
waste into useful energy
and bio-alkanol, so
exciting project.
ELISSE ROCHE: Absolutely.
Next is Jasmine Crow, founder
of Goodr, focused on food waste.
The mission of Goodr
is to reduce food waste
by connecting businesses that
have surplus food to those
who need the meals.
JAMES SULLIVAN: And
fourth is Michael Groves.
The company is
Topolytics, which has
a smart grid for the world's
waste using big data,
mapping, and analytics to
make waste management more
transparent, more efficient,
and more effective,
both commercially and
for the environment.
ELISSE ROCHE: And then there
is Patrick Peter, founder
of Circunomics,
focused on e-waste.
The mission of Circunomics
is to maximize efficiency
for the circular battery
economy with the goal
of achieving zero waste.
And with that, we'd like to
welcome the remaining panels
to the stage for the discussion
portion of today's session.
So welcome Kate Brandt,
Google sustainability officer,
Jim Sullivan, who's
already on stage,
head of the Global
Sustainability Innovation
Accelerator at SAP,
Darien Sturges,
global partnerships manager at
the Ellen MacArthur Foundation,
and Alonso Ortiz Galán,
community engagement manager
at the Global Partnership for
Sustainable Development Data.
[APPLAUSE]
[INAUDIBLE]
JAMES SULLIVAN: What's that?
ELISSE ROCHE: [INAUDIBLE]
Wonderful.
Thank you all for joining,
first and foremost.
To kick things
off, it'd be great
if you could tell us a bit more
about your work and background
in sustainability.
What drew you to this work,
and why is it particularly
critical today?
KATE BRANDT: All right.
Well, huge congratulations
to our winners.
Can we give them a
round of applause?
Can we do round of
applause for our winners?
[APPLAUSE]
Elisse is right.
I got to serve as
one of the judges,
and there was some
really stiff competition
and some other really
exciting proposals.
So thank you to everybody
for participating,
and we're thrilled
to be here, and it's
been such a great partnership
with you, Jim, and the SAP
team.
Yes, so as Elisse mentioned,
I serve as the Google
sustainability officer.
And circular
economy is something
that I'm personally
really passionate about,
and that we have been
very focused on at Google.
So going back to 2015,
we made a commitment
that we wanted to embed
circular economy principles
into our infrastructure, our
operations, our products,
and our culture.
And a big part of
making that commitment
was also our global partnership
with the Ellen MacArthur
Foundation, whom we've
worked with really closely
ever since then.
And for us, this work really
spans across our operations,
from how we manage our data
centers that, of course,
make Google Cloud possible,
to our global real estate
portfolio, our supply chain,
our consumer hardware.
And also thinking about
the role of Google
technology in enabling everyone
to accelerate this transition
to a circular economy.
So some of my favorite things
that we've been up to lately
are looking at the role of AI
in accelerating the transition
to a circular economy.
We had some really interesting
applicants in that space.
And we see this as a
tremendous opportunity
to combine these mega
trends for major impact.
And we also are doing great
work in our data centers
in the space looking at how
we can reuse, remanufacture,
sell in secondary markets
different components
of our servers,
and really driving
towards a more circular
data center ecosystem.
So just a few things,
but I know we'll
get into more on the panel.
DARIEN STURGES: Hi there.
Darien Sturges from Ellen
MacArthur Foundation.
I would like to echo
some of Kate's thoughts
on how exciting it is--
I think, from my perspective--
to see the geographic diversity
of the finalists here.
This conversation
about circular economy
can be a little bit esoteric,
and, at least in my experience,
a little Eurocentric.
So seeing that there is
some take-up, obviously
in Europe, but here in the
US, and then in Africa,
is pretty exciting.
So as I mentioned, I
lead US partnerships
for the Ellen
MacArthur Foundation,
which is an organization that
is about eight years old now
with the mission statement of
accelerating the transition
to a circular economy.
And we can get into a little
bit about what that means later,
but the broad brushstrokes
are we work with organizations
around the world from
the private sector,
big global companies like
Google, universities.
We work with the public
sector, both at the city
level and the national
level, to drive change.
And that runs the gamut from
very tangible projects--
Kate gave a few examples-- to
more thought leadership pieces
about what technology can
mean for sustainability
and the circular
economy, from cloud,
from artificial
intelligence, et cetera.
So that's an overview of the
Ellen MacArthur Foundation.
Again, I'd like to say it's
great to be here and see
so much interest in the work.
ALONSO ORTIZ GALAN: Thank you.
Thank you for the invitation.
Also very excited to be here
in San Francisco Google Next
and to be partnering with
this exciting initiative.
And thank you all
for being here.
I know it's a hard
a decision to--
with all the amazing
panels going on.
So thank you.
I am the community
engagement manager
for the Global Partnership for
Sustainable Development Data.
And we are a global
network committed
to ensure that we have the
necessary data to achieve
and monitor the SDGs.
We bring together governments,
civil society, multilateral UN
agencies, and the private sector
together to collectively solve
problems and gaps around the
production and use of data.
We don't provide the data
ourselves, or collect data,
but rather, we provide strategic
partnerships, advocacy,
technical assistance,
and pilot initiatives
with partners from the national,
regional, and global level.
We strive to reduce
technical barriers, but also
political ones.
Thanks.
JAMES SULLIVAN: Cool.
So I have a confession to make.
I'm selfish.
We're not live
streaming this, are we?
ELISSE ROCHE: It's recorded.
JAMES SULLIVAN: Oh, we are.
Good.
So I grew up in
upstate New York.
I love the outdoors.
I love the winter.
I love skiing.
Kate and I just had a
wonderful conversation.
I got involved in
the climate change
discussions probably
20 years ago,
because I love those
outdoor spaces,
and I'd like them to be
available for my lifetime.
But I've also had some of the
best times with my family,
with my kids in the mountains,
hiking around, skiing.
And I want those spaces to be
available in their lifetimes
as well.
The second point, my
daughter is an athlete.
Has rowed crew for many years.
She spends four or five hours a
day on the water in the rivers,
and comes back with a report
on what's floating down
the river that particular day.
So two really sobering
statistics on climate
change in the US
alone, $1.5 trillion
in damages from
natural weather events
and disasters related to
extreme weather around that.
And then for plastics, I think
everybody's heard the stat,
there may be more fish than
plastic in the ocean by 2050.
So on a personal level,
I'm doing this for my kids,
for our planet.
But it also needs to make
a lot of business sense.
So from an SAP perspective,
for the past 47 years,
we have been managing--
had the privilege to manage our
customers' financial data flows
and material data flows.
We run-- 77% of
financial transactions
float through our
systems on a daily basis,
typically close to
80% of material flows,
whether sneakers, whether
plugging in your iPhone,
whether that.
And if we can merge
that data along
with environment and social
data to allow businesses
throughout the world to make
better business decisions,
we can really make a huge
change in the world, so.
ELISSE ROCHE: Wonderful.
Thank you for the
introductions and sharing
more about your interests
and background in this space.
So another question for you
about the circular economy.
It's a tough one to define.
How would you define a circular
economy in a simplified way,
and how can the
circular economy help
to navigate the often
inverse relation
between economic growth and
environmental degradation?
Whoever wants to jump right in.
JAMES SULLIVAN:
[CHUCKLES] An easy one.
ELISSE ROCHE: Yeah.
KATE BRANDT: Well,
I have to say,
I like the definition
of the circular economy
that we've gotten from the
Ellen MacArthur Foundation
that it's about keeping
products and materials in use,
designing out waste
and pollution,
and regenerating
natural systems.
I think that, to me, feels
like a fairly concise way
of conceptualizing
what I know can
feel like a very complex topic.
And I really appreciate
also the element-- as Jim
was saying-- of the economy
in circular economy.
And Elisse shared some great
statistics that I often
cite as well, particularly the
Accenture study that showed us
that there's $4.5
trillion of value
that can be realized by 2030.
And what I love so much
about this competition--
and our fantastic winners
and all of you who applied--
is you're showing
this is a reality.
You're developing new
businesses, new approaches
that are decoupling growth from
our use of natural resources.
You're showing that
we can build on all
of the great work,
innovation that's taken place
over the last 200 years, but
chart an entirely different
course forward that
is one of abundance
and one of a totally
different relationship
to natural resources.
So I really commend all the
great work you guys are doing,
and I think it's
really showing how
we can put this
theory into practice
in a really powerful way and a
way that makes business sense.
DARIEN STURGES: Yeah.
I would add to that by saying,
at the foundation, at least,
we tend to shy away from
defining specifically
what the circular economy is.
What we want to do
instead is provide
more of a direction,
and especially
a positive direction.
Elisse mentioned the
inverse relationship
between growth and
resource use, and we
want to provide more of a
positive framework that allows
for resource use without--
or I would say, a better
use of the resources we have
is probably another
way of defining it.
And I think the other slight
differentiation I would make
is that we think
about circular economy
as an upstream and a
systems design issue,
rather than just managing the
symptoms of the problem, waste,
for example.
To us, it's the
choices you make early
on in the process,
the materials you use,
whether or not you design
for single-use servings,
such as the water
bottles below us.
That has impact.
And making those choices
early on in the process
has a much bigger
exponential impact
than just trying to figure out
what to do with the plastic
that we pump out every year
at the end of its life.
The final differentiation
I would make
is thinking about
things like consumption
in a slightly different way.
For instance, we
tend to even shy away
from saying "consumption,"
thinking that you don't really
consume anything
unless you eat it.
So thinking about the resources
that businesses or individuals
use as materials that
are going to be used over
and over again, or at least
can be used over and over again
rather than simply
consumed, I think
is another way of at least
directionally getting
at what we mean by the
term circular economy.
ALONSO ORTIZ GALAN: I
think what's interesting
about circular economy is
that it seems something
that's kind of revolutionary.
And in the end, it's
because we married to idea
that the way we produce right
now is the only possible way.
We are just so anchored
on this paradigm,
and I think it's very
interesting to see how many
like these five finalists are
attempting to change that.
And I think sometimes,
it's also about--
we think the solutions are only
going to come from one sector.
For example, government
pushing policies
and pushing everyone to comply.
But it's not about that.
It's a win-win in which,
actually, businesses
can benefit from
inspecting their processes
and making conscious decisions
about how to reduce costs,
their waste, their impact, and
how to think of how they insert
themselves in a
broader ecosystem,
and how they impact themselves
and future generations.
JAMES SULLIVAN: Yeah.
From my thought, I think it's
really a paradigm change.
And the reason-- so
we've been in this space
for years and years of ERP,
Enterprise Resource Planning.
And what you're really
seeing is the definition
of enterprise changing.
It used to be, if you did a
good job in your own four walls,
check the box, you're all set.
And now consumers are demanding
end-to-end transparency.
Was the cobalt in my battery
sourced from slave labor,
or from child labor?
What happens at the end of life?
It doesn't go away anymore.
It goes into a river,
and it goes somewhere.
So from that
definition, you need
to not only take responsibility
for your own actions,
but your suppliers' actions,
your customers' actions,
and how do you pull
all that together.
And the second thing
is the definition
of a resource is
really changing.
In the past, it was enough
to form, fit, function,
and we're good.
End of day.
And now we need to know, again,
the associated attributes.
How much water was used in
the making of this resource?
How much carbon was used in
What happens to that
resource at end of life?
And increasingly, I
like to think of it
in stocks and flows.
If you look at some of
the circular statistics,
we're really only cycling
about 9% of materials globally.
And some of those maybe
should be in place
for a long period of time.
But some of those, if you
open a brand new good,
and you take the packaging off,
and you throw the packaging
away, you've engaged
with that material
for all of five
seconds and it added
very little value for you.
So it's just the way
we think about that.
So that's a bit of
a negative view.
The positive view is we're in
the age of hyper transparency
with data.
And if we can allow visibility
into those material flows,
that little packaging
that I threw away
becomes a valuable
resource for somebody else
in the right place with
the right technology.
So I'm very optimistic about our
approach here moving forward.
ELISSE ROCHE: Wonderful.
So speaking to the industry
as a whole, what sustainable
or circular economy
principles or practices
stand out to you as
particularly impactful, and why?
JAMES SULLIVAN: Switch up.
[CHUCKLING]
ALONSO ORTIZ GALAN: Perfect.
I think sustainable development
practices that really focus
on the issue rather
than on the solution
are the ones that
could have more impact,
and be more successful,
and gather more acceptance.
For example, UN Environment,
one of the partners in this
initiative who cannot be
here, they developed an online
platform in which they help
countries to find hot spots
of unsustainable consumption
and production practices.
And I think there are many
organizations advocating
for several issues, and many
making the needs visible,
so the information is out there.
I think, sometimes, the focus
isn't in the right place.
So making the practices
respond to solutions,
and thinking of the audiences,
and who they benefit,
I think it's the right way.
[CHUCKLING]
JAMES SULLIVAN:
Which way, right?
DARIEN STURGES: I would say--
I'm obviously excited by a lot
of the new innovations that
are popping up, including the
finalists of this contest.
But I think what I'm probably
the most jazzed about
is the new collaborations
that are popping up,
because when we talk about
system change, or changing
the paradigm, it's going
to require collaboration
across the value chain, but
also between the private sector
and the public sector.
And that's happening.
So this collaboration with
Google and SAP is one example.
The foundation is
launching a new initiative
around the global
food system, which
is helping to spearhead a
partnership between some
of the leading food brands
and four global cities.
So it's that spirit of
collaboration that I think
is really going to
drive systemic change.
KATE BRANDT: That's great.
Yeah, I was going to touch on--
I'll pick up on food system.
I think this is an area where
I see so much opportunity.
And Elisse showed us
the butterfly diagram,
as it's called, at the
beginning of the presentation.
And I think that whole left
side of the diagram looking
at the biocycle presents
such tremendous opportunity.
And I know one of our finalists
today is working in this space,
in applying technology to reduce
food waste, which is fantastic.
And this is something
that I'm really
personally passionate about.
This is something we've been
thinking about at Google.
We've done a lot of work
on applying technology
to food waste in
our own kitchens.
We're now applying machine
learning and gaining
new insights.
So I see tremendous
opportunity there,
and I was thrilled to see one
of our finalists really looking
at that topic.
And the other one that I
think we don't often focus on
in these conversations but
that we really like to bring up
is the role of safe chemistry
and healthy materials.
That when we are endlessly
cycling material back
into the system, we also
need to be really confident
that that material is safe
for people and for the planet.
And so that's an aspect
of the circular economy
that I believe is
really important,
and that we have done
work with the foundation.
You may have seen a paper we
published on this last year.
But I also see that as
a really important piece
of the dialogue.
And I met some folks
in the audience
who are developing a
materials marketplace
to create more transparency.
We've done a lot of work
on this, particularly
in the building materials space.
But that's another aspect
to the circular economy
that I think is really
important to focus on.
JAMES SULLIVAN: Yeah, I'm going
to throw the 800-pound gorilla
out there for
business, which is,
if you have a supplier that's
providing you virgin materials,
you can ask for form, fit,
function, price, everything
exactly to your specification.
If you were looking at
secondary markets for materials,
what if the quality
isn't what you expect?
What if the quantity
that you're expecting
isn't what you expect?
What if the quantity
and quality are good,
but they show up in a location
that you didn't expect?
So one of the proofs of concepts
we've run fairly recently
is really, how do you do
that at a commercial scale
for a large company
that's gathering
these secondary
market materials?
And how do you tie it into
integrated business planning
for your business?
What happens if the
quality isn't quite there?
Can I still get away
with making my products?
What do I need to do
to post-process it
in order to do that?
What do I need to do
with my logistics systems
for just in time to get the
right quality components
together in the right place?
So for the first
time, it's really
tying it to the core
business process,
and tying it to profitability,
as you look at that at scale.
So I think there's a lot of
great examples of circular
within closed loops
within companies.
There's becoming a
lot of great examples
of closed loops within
small ecosystems-- auto
manufacturers, and certain
battery recyclers, and parts
suppliers.
There's not really a good
example of open ecosystem,
open loops that are happening.
And as we get to
material marketplaces,
we really need to get to that
point of increased supply
and transparency to handle some
of those risks to business.
ELISSE ROCHE: Great.
Thank you.
So pivoting a little bit
to talk about technology.
Here we are at
Google Cloud Next.
We've mentioned machine learning
and artificial intelligence.
But what, in your
mind, in your opinion,
is the role of data in
sustainable development,
and in sustainability
more broadly?
That's also one to start
with Alonso, given the Global
Partnership team.
ALONSO ORTIZ GALAN: Thanks.
JAMES SULLIVAN: Who knows data.
[CHUCKLING]
ALONSO ORTIZ GALAN:
And here, I'm
just preaching to the choir,
but data is the lifeblood
of sustainable development.
It's the way we understand
the problems we have at hand,
where they're located,
who are they affecting,
what are the right
policies to put in place,
how to course-correct
these policies,
and ultimately,
to achieve impact.
So the data value chain
crosses across policy-making.
And I think that for
data to truly power
sustainable development,
there's two conditions that
need to be met.
And one is data has to
be about social justice.
So oftentimes, the more
marginalized people
in the world aren't
counted in the data.
They are either missed
by censuses and surveys.
They are hidden behind
statistics and averages.
And in order for data to
be truly about sustainable
development, it has to
be about all and for all.
And the second
condition, I think,
it's for data to
be a public good.
So oftentimes, data--
or lately, data
is referred to as the new oil.
I think this framing just
conceals the power of data.
Data is infinite.
Data increases
value as it's used
and it's collated
with other data.
And if the right standards,
policies, and infrastructure
are in place, data can
truly be a public good.
JAMES SULLIVAN:
Keep mixing it up.
I'll go.
The other thing I think
is incredibly important
is getting people the right
data at the right time
as they're making a
decision becomes vital.
You could have the
best data in the world,
and if it's not there
when you're acting on it,
it's not going to be helpful.
So our team in the UK ran a
project called the Plastics
Challenge last year.
It was a guy named
Steve Jamieson, Michelle
[? Hickey. ?] Great, great work.
They followed consumers
around-- not in a creepy way,
but in a gathering data kind
of way-- for about a month
and gauged their every
interaction with plastic.
I get up in the morning,
I eat my yogurt,
I throw the aluminum lid
away, I toss the cup.
Here, I grab my plastic water
bottle, I go to the gym.
What do I do with that all?
And out of that,
through partnerships,
we ran a three-day
design think and came up
with a lot of cool solutions.
But if you come up
to me afterwards,
I've got one app that
is really interesting.
And what it does is it takes
the idea of the data that's
collected around this,
puts it into a machine
learning algorithm.
So with your phone, you can
snap a picture of a water bottle
and know what it's made out of.
It's PET.
Oh.
And then it'll use
geolocation to know
where you are and know what
the options for recycling
that water bottle as a consumer
might be within that region.
So this is up and
running in the UK,
and it's one example of
putting data in the right hands
to make a decision
at the right time.
We just announced
last week, the PR
went out with Bumble Bee tuna,
doing blockchain traceability
with tuna.
Again, a really cool app.
And it allows you to scan
a bar code on your tuna
that you're buying,
and it will show you
exactly where that fish was
caught, what the fisherman's
lifestyle was like, what the
normal catch for that product
is, whether it's endangered.
And then with the company,
the fair trade implications
of that.
Like, oh, this is a
community that we're
providing gloves for so they
don't hurt their hands when
the lines come in.
All super valuable data at
the right time as you're
making a consumer
buying decision.
And then it has to be fun too.
So if you go to
the next page, it's
got recipes for how you use
all that delicious tuna.
So it's combining
the traceability
and the social aspects
along with consumer aspects
and really interesting projects.
KATE BRANDT: Those
are fabulous examples.
I want to hear more
about your take a photo,
identify the product.
But yes, I totally agree.
And I think just to
build on that, the way
that I think about it
is, I think we're really
moving from the
age of information
to the age of knowledge.
We've generated so many data
sets over the last couple
of decades.
But now, we're able to
unlock those data sets
to be really actionable.
And I think there is
tremendous opportunity
to utilize data to
empower communities,
to empower policymakers,
to empower individuals
to drive sustainable change.
And one of my absolute
favorite examples of this
is a project that we worked on
with two wonderful NGOs, Oceana
and SkyTruth, which is
called Global Fishing Watch.
And so this is one of
these amazing examples of,
we're able to take
this huge global data
set, which is that every
ship that is on the high sea
is constantly pinging out
its location every day.
And so we're able to
take that data set,
and with a machine
learning algorithm,
recognize what did a
fishing boat look like as
compared to a cruise
ship, or a tugboat,
or any other kind of vessel.
And then what did it actually
look like when it was fishing.
And then we utilized our
massive cloud compute
and our geomapping capabilities
to create a real-time heat
map of where is global
fishing activity taking place.
And then communities
have been using this data
to create marine
protected areas.
So there's actually five
new marine protected areas
that have been created
just since we launched
this tool a few years ago.
And it's enabling
communities to take control
of their resources, to
drive towards conservation,
and to partner with
the fishing communities
to also enable
them, but to do it
in a much more sustainable way.
So one example
that I love, but I
think of really putting
that data in people's hands
so they can drive really
positive sustainable action.
ELISSE ROCHE: Wonderful.
DARIEN STURGES: I
don't have much to add.
ELISSE ROCHE: OK.
Well, there you have it.
JAMES SULLIVAN: [INAUDIBLE]
ELISSE ROCHE: So also a
followup on technology.
So what are the opportunities
to leverage-- in addition
to the examples
that you shared--
to leverage modern
technology, especially machine
learning and AI for
a sustainable future?
What can we do today?
I think it'd be great
to hear some insights
from the AI and the circular
economy report that went out
just a few months ago.
KATE BRANDT: Yeah, absolutely.
So I alluded to
this a little bit,
but we did a report that we
published just back in January
with the Ellen MacArthur
Foundation, and with McKinsey,
of really looking at
this intersection point
of circular economy and AI.
And we particularly did a drill
down into the food system,
and into consumer hardware.
And I think some of
our major takeaways
were the ways in which--
as we've been talking about--
AI can help us to
drive new insights.
So for example, we
looked at the opportunity
to design better products.
And we're starting
to see examples.
For instance, the
European Space Agency.
They have been using
AI to develop better,
more sustainable materials.
So we're seeing that as
a tremendous application.
Equally, we're
starting to see AI
applied in really interesting
ways to business models.
So some of you may know
the company Stuffstr.
They're a great
circular business.
And they utilize
machine learning
to set the price
for their products,
for their secondary
use products.
So they are able to scan, what
is the price for a new product?
How did they set a
fair price, but that
also enables them
to make a profit
and continue to
run their business?
So I think we're starting
to really see that AI--
and particularly
machine learning--
can be applied to accelerate
these new business models,
and to enable new insights.
And in fact, many of our
applicants for this contest
really showed that
in exciting ways.
So I really thought those
insights were useful.
And equally, we've
been experimenting
on this in Google, inside
of our data centers.
So we took a machine
learning algorithm
and applied it to our data
center cooling system.
And we basically created
an AI-powered efficiency
recommendation system.
So it looked at power,
temperature, pump speeds,
other data sets that we
had for how the cooling
system was operating.
And then it would
recommend, how could we
operate more efficiently?
And then we put it on autopilot.
And it was just making those
recommendations on its own
and getting a 30% increase in
efficiency in our already very
highly-optimized data centers.
And I love that
example because it
means we can deliver cloud
even more sustainably.
But also, it points to
the huge opportunity
that machine learning presents
to optimize many other systems.
So those are just some
of my favorite examples.
JAMES SULLIVAN: Yeah,
I think Kate's grabbed
all the good ones.
We're doing stuff
in similar areas.
The one I would add is
logistics, and the ability
to move things around
much more efficiently.
Look at loads, look
at the way factories
operate, and core
business, which I think
is vitally important.
Kind of a funny aside, but
from you talking about the data
centers, I got back
from our Shanghai labs,
and they've got this all set
up within the coffee machine.
So if your milk is running
low, somebody gets a warning,
and it can predict which
machines and what milk time.
So simple examples like that,
of real-world experience.
We've done it in our Vancouver
labs around the trash bins
to know when the recycle and
when the trash is getting full.
And learn some
real-world results
from that, like, in a mobile
environment like that,
the sensors might
not be as robust
as you would want them to be.
But I think the big areas
are within logistics.
Certainly, it's within
dematerialization.
It's looking at ways of moving
contracts around rather than
moving containers
around, if you have
similar things with different
companies in different areas.
And I think we're really
all just scratching
the surface on the potential.
So this contest was
a great way to work
with a number of
companies that have
some brilliant
ideas in the space
and figure out ways to
make those a reality.
DARIEN STURGES: And what
I would add to that--
taking it back to
the very high level--
is, when I think about the
evolution of our foundation,
we spent five years
basically just trying
to get the message out,
creating a framework,
mobilizing folks
around that message.
We've needed to evolve
because the debate has now--
or the acceptance
level of that message
has led us to need to put
those principles into practice.
We've said things that were,
again, very high level.
Things like waste plus
information equals an asset.
Actually putting a phrase
like that into practice
is an extremely difficult thing.
And it's only through
partnerships and interest
from companies like
SAP and Google,
and some of the advances that
have happened in computing,
in AI and machine learning
over the last couple of years,
makes that a reality.
Jim mentioned the app of
taking a photo of plastic,
and advancements in
image recognition
allows you now to basically take
a photo of waste and rethink
what that means,
or it allows you
to make that link between
the physical world
and the digital world.
And that opens up just
an enormous amount
of possibilities to get that
waste to places, situations
where it's got a value,
and by definition,
isn't waste anymore.
ELISSE ROCHE: That's great.
Thank you.
So also a followup
question on something
that we touched
on briefly before
that I discussed in the
presentation earlier, the SDGs.
We've been talking
about sustainability.
We've been talking about
the circular economy.
But digging a little bit
deeper into the Sustainable
Development Goals,
and especially
into SDG 12, responsible
consumption and production,
what would you say are
some of the challenges
unique to SDG 12?
What is something that needs
to be addressed today in order
to achieve that goal by 2030?
Would love to hear your
thoughts on that, Alonso.
ALONSO ORTIZ GALAN: Thanks.
Of course, Elisse.
So I think what's
interesting about the SDGs is
that they present a--
while they're individual
goals, in the end,
it's a comprehensive
picture of all the things
we need to tackle in order to
achieve long-lasting change.
So all these goals are
interconnected to each other.
So for example, SDG 12 cannot be
achieved if we don't also work
on gender equality, and
protecting the environment,
and resources, and, for
example, many other things.
But I think the challenges--
and I talked about our work.
We think about
this all the time.
how it's not only about the
technical barriers, but also
the political ones.
And I think SDG 12
has the same things.
It requires a more coordination
at the national level,
ensuring the right approach,
scientific evidence.
Obviously, the use of
data, bringing different
stakeholders together to
innovate and think of new ways
to improve consumption
and production.
So once again, in order to work
towards a circular economy,
we need to think of the broader
picture, and how all of this
is connected to each other.
JAMES SULLIVAN: So for the
non-geeks in the audience,
when you put environmental
people together
with technology people, you
get an awful lot of acronyms.
[CHUCKLING]
SDG 12, Sustainable
Development Goal,
is about the production and
consumption, as Elisse said.
And for the geeks onstage that
have dove into the details,
it has some sub-targets
on halving food waste
in the world.
So two of our winners are
looking at the food waste
is a major issue, one from a
developing country perspective,
one from a developed
country perspective.
Same issue.
Two very different solutions
to how you address that.
It's got a goal of
reducing chemical waste.
reducing waste in general.
To me, the one that's
most interesting
is there's a goal and an
aspiration for companies
to report publicly on
sustainability data.
And this is where
I think you get
the biggest bang for
the buck, is actually
tying financial data
for corporate reporting
to environment and social data.
And at SAP, we're on year
eight now of our integrated
report, where we're
reporting all of that,
but we're looking
at the environment
and the social impact
on our company,
and reporting that out on how
it affects our profitability.
So I'd encourage you
to take a look at that.
We just put a new report
out a couple of weeks ago,
and we've got a diagram
where you can transparently
follow the flows of
which of our KPIs
as a corporation-- not
environment and social--
affect each other.
And some of them, like
employee retention,
has a fairly big effect
on profitability.
If we lose 1% of employees,
it's $55 to $65 million
in profitability hit for that.
So it's a really
good way of tying
together environment and social
along with core financial
performance.
And it's one that I think more
and more companies need to do,
because it really
helps steer the company
to make the right decision
for financial reasons, which
also has a pretty big
environment and social impact.
KATE BRANDT: Don't have
anything else to add.
ELISSE ROCHE: Great.
Well, thank you.
So thinking about the
finalists, they've
come up in the
conversation today.
You mentioned food
waste in particular.
Looking at their applications
and at their proposals,
what from their proposals
was particularly noteworthy
for you in assessing them?
And in your opinion,
what was innovative?
What is their potential
to drive impact at scale?
JAMES SULLIVAN: Turn it
over to our esteemed panel.
KATE BRANDT: Oh, yeah.
Well, as I said, I'm thrilled
about all the finalists.
And frankly, I think there
were many other really strong
applications.
And I think what I really
appreciated about them--
as Darien said--
was just the wide
variety of applications.
The geographic diversity, from
looking at the food system,
to looking at more technical
materials like batteries.
I was really heartened
by how representative
all of the finalists were of
the many different opportunities
and areas that we can innovate.
So I was particularly
excited about that.
And as I hinted that, I've
gotten really interested
in the food system.
And I was really excited to
see that focus in the food
system, because let's
face it, a third of food
is getting wasted.
We have to figure this out.
And I think technology has
such a critical role to play.
And also, it was
just so heartening
to see how people are thinking
about using our technology--
and of course, SAP's technology
too-- because we ask ourselves
this question all the time.
How can we utilize
Google technology
to enable more
sustainable outcomes?
And you all thought of
things that we had never
thought of before.
So that too was, I thought,
just really exciting to see.
DARIEN STURGES:
And I would say I
don't have a favorite as well.
I think, at the foundation,
we focus on material flows.
And when you look around
the world at the important--
or at least the
key material flows
that we need to
tackle as an economy,
you look at textiles,
you look at food waste,
as Kate mentioned,
you look at e-waste,
and you ask the question,
are we using the resources
that we have in the most
effective way possible?
And I think all of
these applicants, all
of these finalists have
figured out how to do that.
Or at always have
a model that gets
us to start attacking that.
So all really cool,
all great applicants.
Looking forward to see over
the next six months bring.
ELISSE ROCHE: Absolutely.
So we're getting close on
time, and definitely want
to allow some time
for questions.
But as a lightning
round, quickly, closing
question for the group.
What is one thing
that everyone today
can do to be more
sustainable and to minimize
their footprint?
DARIEN STURGES: I was
thinking about that earlier
when you first threw that at me.
And I think whether you're
a business or an individual,
every decision really comes
down to two key questions
that you need to ask about
a product or a thing,
whether you're producing
it or using it.
One is, how is that
thing going to be used?
And then two, what's
going to happen
once it's done being used?
And I think just having
that in your head
can really go a long
way to helping you
or your company
make better choices.
KATE BRANDT: That's great.
And I think, of course, so
many opportunities for us
to solve these challenges and
drive solutions that work.
But also, I think bringing this
home with us is so powerful.
And I always get so excited.
I feel like I've had
so many people recently
tell me how much their kids
are interested in this topic.
And I think this is their
future, as Jim said.
So I think bringing this home,
and engaging with your family,
doing composting at home,
ensuring you're recycling,
looking at bringing
green cleaning products
into your home, thinking
about more sustainable ways
of getting to work,
or getting your family
to an outing on the weekend.
I think these can feel like
really small decisions,
but they really do
add up, and I think
it's an opportunity
for all of us
to lead by example
and to really partner
with the next generation
and seed this behavior
really early, because
if we all do this stuff,
the world would
look very different.
ALONSO ORTIZ GALAN:
I have to agree.
It's about those
consumption decisions.
And whenever confronting a new
buy or purchase, just thinking
of, where is it coming
from, and how does it
affect someone, either
someone who's producing it.
And as you said, at the end of
the life cycle of that product,
where's it going to end up?
But also asking, do I
really need that thing
that I'm going to buy?
I think that's really important.
And while it's hard to always
having to think and rationalize
every purchase that we
make, it's important.
It's those small changes
that really add up, I agree.
And I think the more we can
all not get into techniques
like Marie Kondo, or
declutter our life,
or things like that,
because we're constantly
asking these questions,
would be great.
JAMES SULLIVAN: Yeah.
Since it's speed round, I
have two really quick things.
But one is in personal life.
So I have another
confession to make.
I'm a musician, and I like
collecting cool instruments.
And it became a problem
a few years ago.
But I've put into
place for my own
purchasing a one-in
one-out rule.
So if I want to buy
anything, whether it's
a new cymbal, or a
sweater, or something,
I need to decide what I'm going
to donate in order to buy that.
And it really changes your
mindset in purchasing,
because I might think I
really like something,
but when I think of
what I have and what
I would get rid of in order to
acquire that, a lot of times,
I'll just say, you know,
I don't really need that.
So just one personal
little interesting hack.
It works with food
too at the end
of the week with my daughter.
We do a pasta a la refrigerator.
And we go through, and we have
to invent a recipe with all
of the food that
we're going to have
to throw out the next day
in order to make a new dish.
So there's innovative
ways to do that
without sacrificing,
but just making
more conscious decisions.
And the final thing
I would say is,
when you're making
purchase decisions,
when you're giving somebody
your hard-earned cash,
you have the ability to ask
hard questions and make choices.
And don't always make them on
the value of the transaction.
Make them on the
values of the company
you're transacting
with for the long term.
And just those two
things will, I think,
really help change behaviors.
DARIEN STURGES: I guess the
final thing I would say too
is that the reason why we talk
so much about systems, design,
and changing the system
is because we don't
want people to make sacrifices.
When we think about SDG 12,
or responsible consumption,
or however you
want to term it, we
don't want Jim to buy
less cool guitars.
We just want the old guitars
to go to the right place.
And if we can create
those kinds of systems,
then there aren't
really bad choices.
But again, that's a tall
order, and that's a huge left.
So we would say that
that's a long-term project,
but that's the end goal.
ELISSE ROCHE: Wonderful.
Thank you so much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]